let's think about what we've seen over
the past few days we found out about
China's spy Base in Cuba and Chinese
hackers reportedly broke into the
networks of hundreds of public and
private sector organizations globally Oh
and before that they launched a Cyber
attack on the U.S Navy we learned
Vladimir Putin has moved nuclear weapons
into Belarus and Iran's oil exports hit
a five-year High according to Reuters
what possibly could that fund its
nuclear program perhaps yet here we are
with an aimless commander-in-chief and a
pentagon focused on all the wrong things
they aren't even trying to hide it
anymore the US military is now on record
saying that those who object to the
sexual mutilation of children are a
danger to National Security and it'll
hurt a military readiness
since January of this year more than 400
anti-lgbtq plus laws have been
introduced at the state level
that number is rising and demonstrates a
trend that could be dangerous for
service members their families and the
Readiness of the force as a whole when I
look at potential candidates I also look
at their personal circumstances it's a
good match for a job does not feel safe
being themselves or if their family
could be denied critical Health Care due
to the laws in that state
I am compelled to consider a different
candidate and perhaps less qualified
Jeremy now is retired to Lieutenant
Colonel Daniel Davis Senior fellow and
Military expert for defense Readiness
Colonel Davis what the hell is going on
in the military here I thought we want
the best and the brightest I don't care
about your sex your sexual preference
your race your religion your color I
don't care about any of those things
shouldn't the military just want the
best to serve this country and defend
this country
that is 100 the case it shouldn't matter
any of those things I mean we we spent
so many years trying to get any kind of
racism or anything else out of the out
of the Force and and I can assure you
from the 20 years that I was in the
service that we did we made a lot of
great progress on that that people
really did care about how effective and
good you were and competent in your job
but now then we seem to be from the very
top elevating things that are not
related to uh compassion capabilities
and it's a little disturbing frankly
that you know that quote there you just
had from the general that she over
overtly said that I would consider
someone who's less qualified uh over
someone else and we just can't have that
if we want to have the best military
that we can and if you look at the
rising threat of China how dangerous
that is how dangerous is that mentality
in the military
uh well look I it's it's divisive I I
think is the real problem uh because
you're basically pitting one side
against another and this has been going
on for quite a number of years and this
is not a way to create cohesion and
cohesion is is actually a combat Force
multiplier necessary for Effective use
in in combat operations well I'm I'm
sorry you're thinking about you know the
these cultural Wars you're thinking
about global warming you're not thinking
about the risks that this country faces
that are serious and Rising but Colonel
here's what Putin said today about
nuclear weapons watch this
the fact is that we have more such
nuclear weapons than the NATO countries
they know about it and all the time we
are being persuaded to start
negotiations on reductions to hell with
them you know as our people say because
in this case in the language of economic
terms this is our competitive advantage
Lieutenant Colonel your reaction
yeah look I mean this is really exposing
uh one of I think a real problem that we
have uh right now with U.S policy is it
relates to the war in Ukraine is that we
don't really know for sure what we're
trying to accomplish or what's going to
make something good for the United
States for example we want to say that
yes we're going to support Ukraine for
as long as it takes but Ukraine's
objective is to completely Drive Russia
out of their uh out of Ukraine and drive
them out of Crimea Putin in that same
speech also said that he would not use
nuclear weapons unless his territorial
integrity was threatened so if we
actually accomplished what Biden says
he's trying to do that would raise the
threat of nuclear warfare to
unacceptable highs and we have to look
out up for American national interests
first and foremost and then we can help
Ukraine around the edges but it can't
come at the expense of our national
security you know to your point uh
here's what zelinski said about
Republicans who don't want to fund an
endless war in another country watch
this
is any candidate or senator who thinks
it costs too much for the United States
to support Ukraine is he ready to go to
war to fight to send his kids are they
ready to die if Ukraine would lose if
Russia would occupy in Ukraine they will
start war with one of the NATO countries
and at this moment the United States
will have to choose the collapse of NATO
or go to war go to war Colonel your
reaction
withhold due respect to the Ukrainian
president that's nonsense but look that
NATO is not threatened at all by you by
Russia right now Russia has shown
graphically over the last 16 months that
their conventional force is barely able
to hold on to about 15 17 percent of its
neighboring country they have no
capacity to go into a 31 member NATO
force and and everyone knows that out
loud so there's really no threat at all
so if if Ukraine and Russia bring their
uh you know War to any kind of
conclusion there is no chance that Putin
can go towards us so our security is not
threatened and our country should not go
to war against Russia we shouldn't even
be thinking about that so I respectfully
disagree with the Ukrainian president on
that one Colonel Davis well said and
thanks for joining me on the angle
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else